un simple grelots pour localiser la
balle françois aveugle de naissance n'a
que ce léger tassement comme repère cela
fait trois ans qu'il pratique ce dérivé
du tennis de table le showdown
je fais des sensibilisations pour parler
du handicap au sein de diverses
associations pour démontrer un petit peu
ce qu'on peut faire quand on voit pas et
puis pour casser un petit peu les idées
reçues des gens qui pensent que quand on
voit pas on peut rien faire piloté par
le service d'accompagnement des
étudiants handicapés de l'université de
versailles saint quentin les journées
andy fac sont donc l'occasion de prendre
conscience des conséquences qu'implique
le handicap et les moyens déployés pour
le compenser avec le chemin de la
concentration doit être optimum c'est un
jeu très intéressant parce que peut être
aussi un jeu de partage
les personnes qui sont voyante se met un
masque sur les yeux se met dans la
situation d'une personne non voyante et
peuvent jouer en faisant un peu plus de
difficultés pour qu'ils apprennent parce
que tout se passe avec l'audition autres
sports qui permettent aux valides et aux
personnes en situation de handicap de se
retrouver le badminton
ça change la
la vision qu'on a des personnes qui sont
dans cette situation ce qu'on comprend
vraiment mieux même si on il faudrait
tous les jours dans ce fauteuil roulant
pour vraiment comprendre ce qu'ils
vivent ça nous permet une approche une
approche différente et une vision
différente de ce qu'ils endurent
toujours le sport mais aussi le théâtre
était à l'honneur pour cette opération
en dix fac au quotidien des associations
étudiantes interviennent aussi pour que
la démarche se poursuivre au delà de ces
quelques jours